all the documents for example
testimonies have been given a goomba
vatican and the orderly officers to our
chief of staff has said at the or that
Pennsylvania is behind this and a
general there and even said if you want
let you speak with our top leader
tuberculin large to the chief of staff
done all of this is in the record so
what are we going to prove because we
sent all these two American authorities
we're sending it we have such a history
for example America said to us catch
these ten terrorists and give them over
yeah we're together right now solidarity
then so we caught them and after
catching them we deliver them to America
I mean okay so now the same thing IDC we
want to head on this organization that
is in our strategic inshallah documents
remember your strategic partners
together in NATO not all that but I want
them given to us and let us try it let's
do what's needed what they said the
court is going to decide I'm sorry but
we can't wait for these kind of
decisions from these kinds of course
because this crime wasn't committed in
the US it was committed in 30 good so
let us make the decision another area
where you are working as an ally in
America is of course Syria and you have
put Turkish troops into the country
you're constructing a buffer zone which
seems to be about is because the Grand
Canyon to protect refugees we had an
American Russian peace plan which you
supported over the past week that seems
to be coming apart with each side
accusing the other you would seem to be
an honest broker who could say who is to
blame for this plan coming apart is that
America's fault or is it rushes she
wouldn't have you gently we have to
determine the truth this does neither
America nor Russia is as close to Syria
as we are America
bazookas idea condition nirosha
musically we have a 911 kilometer border
with Syria no matter aside from that 911
kilometer border museum we have citizens
especially living in around the border
cities under amazon well family ties in
Syria yes Ian surah al Qaeda a club on
that close together hookah Darby's ECJ
but despite all this [ __ ] Syria is
mixed up Burnett surely a Shonda of
course it's not just Syria Iraq is also
like that doctor and what's being said
bring down the dash terrorist
organization in Syria okay truck ethnic
pinky dad are we going to bring down the
dash terrorist organization with now
when you look at America they're saying
pyd YPG we're going to bring it down
with them and as the coalition contrast
how many countries are in Syria how are
there are 65 countries we say look this
queue ID YPG they're also a terrorist
organization and it does one terrorist
organization you get taken out by
another terrorist organization young
it's being done wrong Jim the answer you
had the US defense secretary talking
about continuing to support the YPG is
that a sort sounds like as a source of
great concern for you enjoy keine it's a
source of concern for example in three
days ago America landed two planes for
weapons we're in kobani kimi to whom
they a PYT and YPG they're committing a
grave long before the eyes of the world
now al-nusrah is a terrorist
organization and al-nusrah is also
fighting against the ashes of a sure if
those who are fighting against ash
aren't terrorists terrorists and
al-nusrah also as a terrorist but PYD
YPG the apg
these are the key terror stillborn
children of the PKK a terrorist
organization in my country that I've
added her together I know them they're
the same and we say since there are 65
countries in the coalition each index
get together getting better average a
piece let's bring down Tasha cartel have
no doubt any changes together with to it
that way apart but if you get up and
distinguish amongst terrorists you're
harming turkey Turkey echo to dekalb
solutions because we disturbed by this
terrorist group that you're defending
asses not they constitute a threat to
our country by giving them where
conserve your strengthening this threat
to our future dmz just on the subject of
Russia and America terse then I asked
you at the beginning who was to blame
for what had happened in the past week
more on I get enjoyable Sean all I day I
nebulous I'm all to believe that the one
who bombed that un convoy was the regime
in Argentine animal visit regime the
regime bonded itself that's what the
intelligence coming to us indicates we
used to commit that she met javi and
then right after that America we have
this ain't being delivered by our Red
Crescent miss lady mean after this our
people couldn't go in like I had to
postpone balada that's the situation